the public sees closing history they
think about godfather they think about
maybe soprano maybe goodfellas maybe
bronx tale maybe you know donnie brasco
with lefty they see the movies they
don't you know the movie is what they
know about it
what is kosonostra to you and does it
still have the same meaning today as
they did back in the 80s
first of all it's part of my heritage as
an italian
this came from sicily
it was created in sicily in the 12th
century maybe even a little bit before
it was called clans back then
and they protected the people that's how
golden austria started it became the
mafia instead of clans
it evolved and came into this country in
his home history and there was hundreds
of movies with
al capone and lucky luciano and vito
genevieve and on and on and on so this
has
meaning to me
when i was a kid i was a [ __ ] up in
school i didn't get out of the 8th grade
i didn't have the privilege of growing
up and graduating high school like
michael did
or going to college wanting to be a
doctor
i was a thug
i was in a gang
and godzilla is what kept me alive
you